اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم ارتفاع حجه التوتر بين
كوريا الشماليه وجارتها الجنوبيه حيث
اطلقت بيونغيانغ صواريخ بالستيه باتجاه
البحر الشرقي ودعى زعيمها الى زياده في
الترسانه النوويه في حين عقد الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي اجتماع عن طارئا وشدد على ان رده
على اي استفزاز مباشر سيكون حاسما وقويا
اوكرانيا تقول انها هجمات روسيه بعشرات
مسيرات الايرانيه استهدفت مقاطعات عده
بينما اكدت روسيا انها قصفت قاعده لفوج
النخبه في القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه كما
فرضت التعامل بالروبل الروسي في المناطق
الخاضعه لسيطرتها شرقيه وجنوبيه اوكرانيا
بعد 10 سنوات على عضويتها في الاتحاد
الاوروبي كرواتيا تعتمد اليورو عمله لها
وتنضم رسميا الى منطقه شنغن وتلغي
الاجراءات الحدوديه
فحاملي جوازات السفر الاوروبيه ما يتيح
التنقل بلا تاشيرات بين 27 دوله اوروبيه
بالتزامن مع مظاهرات وصلوات جماعيه
احتجاجات لالاف المسلمين في الهند بعد
تصديق محكمه ولايه اوتار خاند العليا على
قرار هدم حوالي 454 منزل من منطقه تعيش
فيها الاف العائلات المسلمه التي تواجه
خطر التشرد
الى اللقاء